sur la place maïdan à kiev une action
organisée par des proches de soldats
ukrainiens bloqués dans l'usinage ostal
à marioupol
ils doivent amputer des membres même
pour des blessures légères parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de médicaments
il n'y a rien pas d'eau pas de
nourriture
nous ne pouvons pas abandonner ces gars
qui se sont battus pour nous
[Musique]
il ne les sortent pas parce qu'ils
disent que c'est impossible je ne crois
pas que tout soit impossible je sais
qu'il ya toujours un moyen de s'en
sortir et j'en pleure le président j'en
pleure toutes les personnes concernées
bdl et faire sortir tous nos fils nos
maris nos pères
la police arrive la manifestation n'est
pas autorisée elle se déplace vers le
ministère des affaires étrangères
nous écrivons depuis un moment au
président
nous pensons qu'ils avaient besoin de
notre soutien
nous sommes alors tournés vers les
dirigeants internationaux pour qu'ils
nous aident à organiser cette évacuation
le gouvernement ukrainien dit qu'il n'y
a pas de solution militaire pour sauver
les soldats d'assaut ce talent mais
qu'il tente tout sur le plan
diplomatique
c'est pour cela que ces manifestantes et
manifestants sont venus au ministère des
affaires étrangères à kiev il espère que
un autre pays pourrait trouver une
solution et notamment peut-être la
turquie pourrait proposer une solution
d'extraction des soldats pour les
emmener en turquie et les garder là bas
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre mais pour le
moment la russie ne semble pas prête à
accepter une telle proposition